les slogans n'ont pas changé la tenue
non plus en ce 5e samedi de
manifestation le gilet jaune est
toujours de rigueur sur les champs
elysées mais la mobilisation n'est plus
celle des beaux jours
une foule clairsemée beaucoup trop aux
yeux de mélanie honnêtement je suis déçu
je sais pas comment ça se passe ailleurs
dans paris mais aussi en tout cas je
suis déçu le froid les appels répétés
des autorités à rester chez soi et
surtout les concessions du président mc
ren semble avoir freiné le mouvement
dans son élan philippe un retraité qui
n'a pas manqué une manifestation depuis
le début reconnaît volontiers que celle
ci est sans doute sa dernière
je crois que ma croatie diviser le
mouvement pour la chaux un petit peu les
gens se sont dit on a obtenu quelque
chose maintenant il faut que l'économie
reparte
gérard lui reste déterminé il à voter
pour marine le pen à l'élection
présidentielle et avoue n'avoir pas
écouté le secours des manuels mc ren
dont ils demandent la démission ce n'est
pas à l'écouté de son peuple
ne dirige pas son peuple monsieur mâcon
est atteint et que ce banquier je crois
pas que ce soit qui n'est pas dans son
rôle
si les manifestants étaient bien moins
nombreux que les semaines précédentes le
déploiement des forces de l'ordre lui
n'a pas changé
résultat il y avait dans paris selon les
autorités deux policiers et gendarmes
pour chaque manifestant largement
encadré le rassemblement est donc resté
calme pour l'essentiel sauf en fin de
journée lorsque les esprits se sont
échauffés aux abords d'un point de
fouilles de la gendarmerie osait de
pierres et de projectiles
les forces de l'ordre ont répliqué à
coups de gaz lacrymogènes pour disperser
les manifestants violents avant de
sortir le canon à eau pour finir de
convaincre les plus déterminés alors que
les derniers manifestants sur les
champs-elysées se retrouvent encerclés
par les forces de l'ordre
le mouvement des gilets jaunes qui en
est à sa cinquième semaine de
mobilisation semble marquer le pas du
moins sous sa forme actuelle
ici jean françois bélanger radio canada